well the prime minister addressed this
last week in parliament and set out his
understanding of the situation i'd refer
you to his words do you believe the
prime minister of course i do the prime
minister set down the truth of course i
do the prime minister set out his
understanding of this matter in
parliament last week and i'd refer you
to his words as you know sue gray is
conducting an inquiry into this matter
and i fully support the prime minister's
request for patience while that inquiry
concludes dominic cummings dominic
comings and dominic cummings and others
have said that the prime minister was
warned this party shouldn't go ahead if
the prime minister lied and lied to
parliament he should resign shouldn't he
well i'm not going to get into
hypotheticals the ministerial code is is
clear on these matters but as you know
sue gray is conducting an inquiry into
the situation i think it's right that we
allow her to conclude that job and you
support and you support the prime
minister unequivocally
oh gosh thank you
russia cena keen to make quite a swift
entrance there wasn't he but uh
certainly putting on record his support
for the prime minister and repeating
that manchester united we've heard from
many government ministers over the last
few days that we need to wait for sue
gray's report before we pass any
judgment on what potentially could have
happened back on all those dates of
potential partying at downing street